when you were born I told you life was
very big and unknown there were animals
and cities and music you'd fall in love
have passions have meaning but no it's
1979 and nothing means anything and I
know you less every day I think maybe
you guys can help me with Jaime how do
you be a good man who does that even
mean notice don't you need a man to
raise a man no I don't think so I think
you're what's gonna work for him you
just feel guilty kisses just being you
you don't know what I'm feeling
men always feel like they have to fix
things for women where they're not doing
anything just be there somehow it's hard
for all of you well I'm not all men okay
I'm just mean well yes and no sure I'm
having a kid seems like the hardest
thing how much you love the kid you're
just pretty much screwed you get to see
him out in the world as a person I never
will what about you it's always about
the mother okay Jesus yeah
so sweetie I don't know if we ever
figure our lives out and the people who
help you they might not be who you're
for or wanted they might just be the
people who show up Jamie and also honest
they never had sex with just the vagina
yeah I have to have sex with the whole
woman that's slightly off topic I had no
idea they heard what a few women working
in the space program needs a computer
yeah there is